up it looked promising you went through
shoot around today but the sore left
ankle they ultimately decided not to go
wait back to her cut by Andrew Wiggins
and Tosh hits him right in stride with
the bounce pass Cindy was cut so Andrew
goes backdoor as he should throw to deaf
Jo with one of those crushing screens
Butler inside the Wiggins and both teams
we've seen
[Applause]
putting him from muddy cutting attached
to the offensive glass and Duncan versus
just standing on the perimeter watching
the game five Timberwolves and double
figures and Andrew Wiggins up the
turnover has an open floor banter with
his fourth dunk of the season to be
shots but the officials disagree and
Lillard is going to get paid with three
free throws get another look at Andrew
the open floor look at the pressure that
that Nick Memphis puts on you great spin
mode by Wiggins who rises for the stop
normally happened it was just a
wide-open area for him to roll into but
actually went to his folks house in
Serbia did a really nice job
a true wickets flying high above the rim
I'm just saying that's something that
may have fallen off of sports radars
radar Andrew Wiggins back on the radar
and the Timberwolves have opened up some
breathing room here to do with Minnesota
being up in the game Derrick Rose well
fancy passing to Robert coming to new
dishes it off to Andrew Wiggins for two
easy ones but and this game we're still
in the balance Wiggins Gibson fighting
for towns comes down with it can't get
it to go
Andrew Wiggins isn't right there that
you
like yeah pogo stick remember they took
those two ah when we thought the shot
grazed the rim and the shot clock
expired Wiggins oh my goodness elevation
alikat Tyus challenge and they have
reason to believe they could turn it
around because last year the pelicans
120 of their final 28 games to get into
the foot pro season here with 14 nice
pass by towns to Wiggins starts with
depth there he catches it on the post
verses out near the three-point line yes
sometimes no Andrew Wiggins is the
beneficiary of the double team of
karl-anthony towns and Andrew Wiggins
throws it down with emphatic style that
was an iron man out there take it
you see that coming now it's just
unabated it's one of the things he's
been doing he's even tried to confuse
and sort of relaxes brave a little bit
by his head religions hammers that put
to speculation on a true cynic trying to
go around his back loses the basketball
and gets a hand on it
Gibson ahead to Wiggins and Andrew will
get the stuff wild pass picked off by
towns has Wiggins ahead of the field and
he puts it down it's a 12-point better
subtly this is Wiggins down more his
athletic ability third field goal look
at the follow off the vert that I told
timbrels get to turnover Wiggins in the
up and for it's going to be only the
second fast-break bucket by the two
holes here tonight they stick that do
your job whoever's got to go to work on
Wednesday morning this because cold
outside and one for Andrew Wiggins I'm
talking about ice hand off by Townsend
Andrew gets over the top grace O'Neill
is offensive fouls when he's wrestling
with guys in the low post and he draws
offensive fouls that way as well Ravens
off the feed for DJ
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the only average at eleven point
two points per game on the season but he
has been on fire this last handful
Wiggins Oh Jude it's an open rack and
flushes it the organization still feels
like they can compete and can win best
with the teams they have right now
Andrew Wiggins with Duncan
witness gets it right back little
two-man game and Wiggins with to stuff
again Carla Jean towns give him dough
oldest playing basketball post up
opportunity just had we decide to play
where he showed two baskets by search
and a Kogi what do you think about the
moves the Sixers made as Wiggins
splashes that down has great back time
and a pass by dang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wiggins tone Iraq
[Applause]
[Music]
awakens
seriously attack in the duck goodness
break-ins with the flush these four
tried to get into the cut that tonnes
Andrew Wiggins Tolliver whips it inside
and Wiggins will oblige with the done
just surprising you know when you do
these things you need to get interesting
result so Dario shark just anterior gets
to the river throws it down drop to
Stephon Marbury but they actually
drafted Ray Allen you wonder what would
have happened as Figgins was back door
here and Germany's come back door have
so many injuries it misses with the
starter rotations it messes with the
reserve rotations and Andrew Wiggins
messin with the Hornets defense on that
visit hold the Hornets under 40%
shooting in that first half we are at
the break
[Music]
hereafter the Hornets at open up a
nine-point lead explodes more of that
please answer he gets it and he just
fixed that handoff and he just triples
right to the rim and throws it down
that's what I'm talking about this is
the it's been obvious as he has pent
force in all aspects of the game how
about Beverly missing and on the other
end Andrew Wiggins with 82 points and
it's a big blow to the tragedy big big
blow to the Portland Trailblazers who
had a two-game lead Wiggins out of the
timeout nor has had a nice night 15
points two blocks Andrew Wiggins
viciously attacks the rim another
backdoor cut by Andrew Wiggins inside
Wow what a cut by injury Wiggins in a
beautiful feed by quirky Jay was under
mr. 15 to 4 run while I don't know
Tyus Jones what pastor Andrew Wiggins
who skies for the flush
he'd assists he does have one turnover
here tonight so 21 what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content